I feel lighter I feel happier then I can
just be so open and honest it feels nice
Outer Banks star Madison Bailey is
opening up about coming out as pansexual
I'm ready for it
the 21 year olds recently discussed her
sexuality on tik-tok revealing that
she's pansexual Madison is dating
University of North Carolina at
Charlotte basketball player
Mariah Linney I'm not falling I'm not
falling I'm not falling I'm not falling
she introduced her fans to Mariah last
week on her tik-tok account simply
captioning it surprised
okay I'm falling back in May Mariah made
a tick-tock video swooning over Madison
[Music]
and Mariah confirmed their romance last
week when she shared another tik-tok
featuring Ariana Grande's seven rings
[Music]
cute right it wild well on Wednesday the
Netflix star opened up more about her
sexuality during a mental health Q&A
with Lacey Hartsell I very accepting
friends very accepting family right an
industry that's very welcoming and very
accepting
but pros as far as appose go being open
and honest yeah feels so good it does be
so transparent
especially in an industry where a lot of
people want to be in my personal life
it's it's nice that I'm here is my
personal life yeah of it it's fun and
Madison admits that she's one of the
lucky ones for having so much support in
her corner
I feel zero of shame and I feel and I
don't feel that way because nobody's
ever really ashamed before right and I
know a lot of people have had a lot of a
lot a lot a lot of hate and lack of
support I know sorry
if there's countless stories of career
people that did not have support and but
if you're asking me personally that's
just my experience with it
it was worth it the actress also
encouraged fans to be open about their
own sexuality if you're gay you're gay I
was like to be honest I don't believe in
straight people yeah there is real as
unicorns to me and it seems like love is
in the air for the cast of Outer Banks
Madison's relationship news follows her
co-stars chase Stokes and Madeline Klein
who just confirmed they're dating it's
really cool the two made their love
Instagram official when she shared these
snaps writing cats out of the bag back
in April before the cat was out of the
bag the lovebirds played toy when et
to them about their rumored romance for
the people who are gonna want to know
are you guys single
are you dating right now we are kind of
just make sure you fans are really gonna
freak out now when they watch this yeah
what I'm think about it we're friends as
for Madison when et caught up with her
in April she dished about her character
Kiara's on the screen heat with Pope I'm
interested to see how that dynamic is
gonna work out to you because it's like
I made it really clear episode 9 and
then episode 10 I kiss you so it's like
is it just because it was a rush of
emotions or because I didn't realize it
or what what where does it go now do you
think it's real or do you think it was
just kind of like an in the moment thing
I think the love there is real but
Madison people also really like he and
John be together I'm sure you've seen on
social media as much as people love he
and John meet people love Sarah and John
B so III don't know I think because then
we had so many moments in the beginning
and then it just kind of trailed off I
really have no idea where that's at
[Music]